[Music]
so to hear yes I checked out your IG
yeah yeah and you guys check out his IG
v haven't you post some funniest
reactions to things that are happening
online and I saw you react to this story
yeah is this guy from retreat from
Detroit he sued his employer alleging
racial discrimination hmm
and that lawsuit they ended up settling
so when he went into the bank to cash
the settlement checks no bank called the
cops on him and it was pretty much like
racial profiling cuz they saw that yeah
bored like faked a check
so then cops show up and he's like what
the [ __ ] like I've got this money from a
lawsuit and all this stuff and then they
were just like it was he able to sue the
bank again and get another law he's
suing them now yeah the exact same thing
he sued his company what were they
saying is like you're black there's no
way you have much money he only had 53
cents in his checking account
53 says it a second account right
yeah he had three settlement checks
right what does he look like southern
baptists venture and all right looks
like a preacher yeah I was living single
oh it was like fat cow he does oh he had
three checks he wanted to deposit one to
catch one yeah the one he wanted to cash
was like $12,000 what anything crazy
right 13 you're always off by one what
your show started
yeah he wanted the cash at one to buy
truck buy a car because he didn't have a
car right so when he first got the
teller was like where'd you get this
from me like I want a settlement will do
right this she was like alright well the
person that handles these type of
transactions of this size isn't here so
give me a second I had them verify to
deposit a 12 grand check you know three
check
three checks he wanted to cash the last
one so the other two times fifty nine
thousand dollars and twenty-nine
thousand dollars so he deposited the
check and wanted cash immediately well
one of them well what's the cash oh yeah
he just wanted to catch one it's like a
bachelor but if it's over ten thousand
you have to be verified by the manager
right no I mean well I mean cuz they
look at your whole history so I can see
how the bank would kind of red flag it
cuz had 50 to 53 cents yeah um and and
if you wanted a cash right away what
they tend to do the most respectful and
like the safe way to do that they go we
can't yet whip the place to hold on it
yeah I don't really some of the funds by
typically about five hundred no it's a
hundred a lot hundred bucks if they even
allow that the most part they don't they
don't geo do you think this is a case
where many people are just ignorant as
to how the bank works well I think this
is the case where the bank really [ __ ]
up call the cops cuz what you should
have done you just run it through the
system and it already has its own Jason
as they ran it and it couldn't prove
that the checks were issued by the law
firm they had like strips on it to prove
that it was fraudulent checks and then
so he that's when he called his lawyer
I'm calling his lawyer he was like what
the [ __ ] like why and then the lawyer is
like pretty much because he's like there
is it's impossible no one is submitting
these or like having issuing these
fraudulent checks because I just went to
this major law firm who got this cheque
from this major corporation what I call
a courier yes I know like how how is
this what yeah they [ __ ] the bank
[ __ ] up oh absolutely yeah absolutely
they were just saying like hold on
we didn't racially discriminate it was
just we were looking at the actions no
matter who it was we would have raised
some red flag
it sounds trudeau and so they're saying
like you know this bank is a diverse
business serving a diverse community and
all this stuff but whenever like Oh even
the teller was blacking all that like I
don't mean [ __ ] I don't mean
that could be true but whatever lawyer
could just be like let's go let's hit
this oh yeah I thought you would have
did it I definitely would impress all
gasp let's sue they asked to absolutely
so when you say we left there and went
to chase and chase except that all three
chicks yes because the issuing bank from
the law firm is from Chase we don't know
that Oh cuz that would make sense
because then it can verify if the
money's there or not and if it's all
yeah yeah wondering one of the people
that we working with him was black and
that's what the bank tried to use as it
is oh the person who was black it was
like look we got a black employee
I mean black definitely should be sorted
for police officers show up because this
teller ends up telling him like oh right
now our verification system is downsized
to manually verify yeah so she ends up
leaving and saying like I'm gonna go
call and verify this but she's she just
called the cops and that's the Warlock
show up and then start questioning him
and saying like hey the bank things that
you like we just need to find out
where'd you get this money from where
these checks from Barriss and then
that's one like he gives him he gives
them like they're his lawyers we have
this card and he calls up his own lawyer
to to try to clarify everything and they
were just being difficult and the
lawyers that I've never seen anything
like this in my attacks grant but the
cops will called on someone for trying
to deposit their settlement check ever
can we see can we take another look at
this guy okay cuz in defense of the bank
I'm calling I'm calling somebody the
cops every time Oh every time I see
somebody dressed like a vampire I'm
calling the cops he looks like a bank
manager he looked like his name is
Chauncey I've never met a threatening
Chauncey looks like a flag to me I don't
know no no and then it gets you there he
don't even have face in her that's the
least threatening black guy ever any
black guy with no face on her
I open hand slap you open in front of
cops to hear you saying there's no black
vampires no booklet you see he just
needs to say that's all in if not on
purpose so for the first lawsuit that
was racial discrimination was that war
was that what it was a federal thing
like poor colored they don't even give
detail like they just said it was this
job they say the name of the book where
does he live in Alabama KKK town or
Detroit yeah poor guy
you just have a face that like [ __ ]
invites it's a small baby it's a small
bank yeah all about bigger one no my mom
my banker there for two years and years
[ __ ] no my mom in law does is was a vice
president and they they it's very like
they it's a whole racket the small banks
are a whole racket like they have one
I'm not even saying this involves the
case is kind of different but really
they kind of build the bank up for like
a couple of months and or even like
maybe two years and the game in that
whole business is to just [ __ ] sell
it to like a bigger one like of America
chase yeah and they just keep on selling
it or they sell to another private bank
and they keep on shuffle all that
[ __ ] money around it's so interesting
it's kind of like what doctor doctor was
telling us about a lot of the real
estate market
[Music]
so yeah I would own that goddamn Bank
I'll tell you then I know I would haul
net buying a bank that's where the
money's at I wonder if like he's
standing with the towel and he sees the
walks I mean he sees the cops walking in
if you just went like this he was like
let me guess who they're for nah no no
no but like yeah the smirk cuz he knew
what the [ __ ] was about hey this thing
is not like ya come at me like he's a
little smirk on his bank money hey what
if he wears that though he got he got a
move the [ __ ] out of Detroit why though
he's [ __ ] breaking in the dome yeah
yeah because he got too much money to
live in you know robbers face all in the
paper and [ __ ] like that you got to get
the [ __ ] up out of there why do you
think Eminem lives in Detroit in the
[ __ ] best neighborhood with the
biggest [ __ ] gates ever of all time
and a fully armed he still lives out
there oh yeah yeah he knows everything
Eminem because of his life it's just a
byproduct of my life
your wife loves Eminem oh yeah the new
album came out by the way yeah the
minute the album draught she already
memorized because I like I hit her up
but she's like the girl you think I
didn't write it already memorized like
for the [ __ ] whatever songs I'm like
okay not even kidding the album came out
we had just shot JK news album came out
that night I get home and I'm expecting
to [ __ ] me yeah hundred percent I'm
having sex tonight
we talked about it or I was shooting
something I remember I came home and
then I'm like hey baby and she's got
tears in her eyes and she's like
Eminem's album just dropped like I need
some time just listen to some of it
downstairs and she was movement because
she was in her car for like 45 minutes
listen to it this chick is drilled into
Eminem because she loves that [ __ ] oh I
do I actually think he's amazing
yeah he's a incredible [ __ ] no [ __ ]
choice no no I really do think that
though he's one of the only I think he's
one of the only people in music who
constantly talks about the culture like
at all times like in all of his [ __ ] is
super satirical and really smart like I
love I like him
now she's she actually there's a video
on her channel right now she talked
about it
she has mixed feelings but have to cry
about it
so some songs moved her yeah I know she
was moved for sure no [ __ ] that night
we did not she had to go listen to an
elf [ __ ] duh
he [ __ ] her [ __ ] two years old yeah
definitely [ __ ] if I could do that
yeah yeah oh god it's game with both
ears so anyway good for him though man
sucks he's got to go through this but
he's raking the aluminum no there's no
these old all right yeah you gotta [ __ ]
me cuz ended up getting a 2004 Dodge
Durango
yeah he was just like just need a car
bro I just need a car that's how are you
trying to do 50 grand
no so three checks right what's the math
fifty nine plus 27 plus 13 I'm not okay
Nikki was here she would have it down to
the [ __ ] cent in three seconds she's
that fun hundred grand I'm just saying
you guys you know you guys can't keep
kick keep you on her level and he's
about to win another one yeah I hope he
wins I really think goes back and opens
another account put all that money in
there and then close this [ __ ] the next
day doesn't have them do all that
paperwork for that that's great yeah
they come out next week an open a
business account for the money right
back hate sir no we're not gonna allow
this we know what you're up to and he's
like is it because I lack
no sir it's not that this is last week
last week when you guys call the cops on
me because I was black was that the
following week when you tried to open
account and he closed the next morning
Oh
because cops called because I was black
you were saying - he was like um he's
like I want to be vindicated
I feel very intimidated because because
I knew that if I would have gotten loud
yes he would have got had me on the
ground for a disturbance of the peace
but I didn't get loud I didn't get
confrontational I did nothing I had a
very long journey and I feel like I have
to go through the same thing again it is
just reading but I do know God is in
control I will be vindicated because I
didn't do anything wrong
right ladies and gentlemen of the jury
let me say that's an openness because
he's absolutely right and he would have
got loud I'm like what the [ __ ] how did
you not see like you see this issue
right now sir calm down I'm not calming
down you guys need the car to [ __ ] that
sir I'm actually gay - calm down [ __ ]
you on the ground haircut now he's now
he's in jail
now he has a record now he's a hostile
black guy right not a man standing for
you smart so it's so [ __ ] up because
of such a vicious cycle we are off the
time people color don't have the luxury
to react as I counterparts would like we
don't have the that the luxury of having
a visceral reaction around cops even
though they're trained to stay calm
we're not
that's the billions we're not trained to
stay calm we can't be led by emotions if
it doesn't hinder someone else on or
somewhere else but around cops you can't
because you'll get tased shot locked up
on some [ __ ] like yo the [ __ ] I wasn't
wrong to miss it so I hope he wins and
gives me some money
yes how much you want just like ten yay
that's all about 2000 2004 Dodge Durango
I'll take three dollars
[Music]